but I have to say congratulations to you  because first of all two things I want  to talk about one of my favorite things  I saw was you winning your award cuz  he's not just like he got my Nabi thing  he's also won a voice Derby so it's like  V God's me he's with the other things so  you're literally online removing his  trophies and yes yeah this is one of my  favorite pastimes but that's what we  love it but that's what I mean you  aren't such a comedian and it's so  awesome and I love that you changed your  Twitter but your Twitter bio it now says  you're currently sleeping with the  sexiest man I'm on their toes like I'm  currently current I don't know about  next week who knows it'll happen I will  not stop talking until you subscribe to  my youtube channel that's right and I  could talk a lot seriously not gonna  stop yep still here not going anywhere I  see you don't walk away from this